i have a a boring hobby
am i reading books related to that
boring hobby i mean you have such an
intense job like
i don't really put a past you to have a
somewhat you know quite boring hobby
most people who are like i feel like
have like intense you know showmanship
right normally have like something that
kind of looks like it brings them back
down
well it's like people you know who like
spend all day every day going to like
metal concerts right yeah it's like yeah
you can't listen to metal at home you
gotta like
relax with some enyo or something right
it was a very successful he was he was a
quarterback in the nfl
and he was like one of the most feared
quarterbacks in the league when he was
playing right
and uh his hobby was to knit
great gigantic like 200 kilo man
knitting scarves for grandma and whatnot
sounds like a very
therapeutic yeah yeah that's what i said
he said it calmed him down yeah yeah
what are your boring hobbies or
interesting hobbies
funny enough like because our job
is our hobby right i've we've had to
like i guess
try to find hobbies outside new hobbies
yeah yeah
yes because every hobby that like at
least i've
pursued i've somehow monetized it oh
yeah and it's kind of like turned into a
job
and i'm kind of the same thing
everything that was once monetized
everything was once a passion for me is
now the job right exactly what you said
exactly
definitely exercise for me but kind of
conor mcgregor oh carmichael we're not
here to take part we're here to take
over
oh look at the island the fighting irish
you know actually not an irish he's not
even an irish
welsh i was gonna say because i i guess
in some aspects you
you know exercise for you probably is
part of the job right yeah
so i feel like for me because i don't
you know i don't really [ __ ] need to
do it i just do it for me it's very much
that's great what do you do what are you
doing cardio and uh lifting stuff
lifting weights like a monkey i guess
feels like you know
you like a monkey that's what it feels
like you know you never just feel like
i'm just literally just lifting things
and i come back the next day and i come
back and lift things again
and sometimes i sit there and i'm
thinking like this is so bizarre why do
we do this
and i just lift things up for an hour
i feel that way on the treadmill where
you just feel like a [ __ ] hamster
like going around the wheel yeah i feel
great so it's like i need to do this but
sometimes i do have this existential
crisis of like what am i doing i
just imagine like aliens coming down to
earth being like what do you humans do
we lift heavy objects and feel great
about it like okay again
thinking that it's to generate
electricity
yeah personally i just find that you
know i'm not really trying to get like
you know in any particular shape i just
find that i sleep better i feel better
when i do it you know occasionally very
good for you yeah
just a promotion of exercise traffic
listeners you
should try exercising i feel like you
know what i mentioned everyone's like oh
he's trying to be like a chat or some
kind of
meathead it's like no it's just chad oh
my god you don't know i'm literally a
chad
you are a hang on just a second i feel
like i'm supposed to be insulted okay
okay no no no no no no no no you people
in the united kingdom
refer to a bogan as a chav is that a
difference
it's completely different
when you hear the word chad what comes
to mind what image springs to mind
the kid who lived next door when i was
growing up
you don't think of like the american guy
in the film who's like a kind of bully
kind of
you know like a joke no yeah he's not
everybody that's normally that's where
the meme came from yeah yeah it's like
oh really he's like
a lot of a lot of like american films
like well he's always a chad
yeah like the jock in the high school
was always chad
or like buddy that's where the meme came
from and that means like
now it's kind of adopted into someone
who's just like now it just means like
someone who i guess is who exercises no
no no no no no it's just kind of like a
strong-willed
man i'd say this like very high
self-esteem like you know
like that's kind of hell yeah i'm the
[ __ ] kind of just someone someone who
typically is
confident is joe rogan a chad
yeah yeah yeah i don't know i would say
he's a
i feel like he used to just mean guy
who's ripped and massive and it kind of
like got blurred along the way to just
like yeah
guy who exudes self-confident energy
but yeah you know a lot of sometimes
people trying to like mock mock them
then it started what was it was the chad
versus the virgin as well yeah
like the [ __ ] was like the
opposite of the chat someone who just
was self-deprecating perhaps low
self-esteem low self-esteem
couldn't get girls that's a virgin a
virgin is
typically pure and innocent and that's
the that's the japanese way of thinking
about it
i i would say that's the japanese
definition of version what pure and
delightful
pure and like you know untainted that's
everyone's idea of a virgin no not on
the internet
the internet doesn't know what to talk
about yeah there's this group of hive
mind of every people
no i don't want to talk about who's on
the internet yeah so you are their
hobbies you get to their hobbies
right yeah yeah so anyway yeah you are a
chart um
you are officially certified chat you've
changed my name to lady chad
honestly honestly if you want internet
rebranding
it might work it could work it could
work
you know what that would be perfect for
that would be like a second channel name
for a youtube channel
your main channel is ladybug
dude this is wasted marketing
top 10 ways to lift